this episode is brought to you by gray
block pizza gray block it is made from
scratch to scratch that itch to stay
human get that gray block pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard in Los Angeles this
episode is brought to you by hood hat
and that is a hat right here you can go
to hood hat come to get that hat I'll
also put them on the Instagram and this
one says Los Angeles Echo Park this one
is in Dodger blue because you love the
Dodgers don't you we also have Inglewood
hat in purple and gold get a hood hat a
hood is where you're from aren't you
from somewhere well let people know we
also have hood hat for rich people like
Beverly Hills Brentwood bel-air Malibu
[ __ ] somewhere rich Hidden Hills if
you want that Drake Kanye Calabasas
lifestyle we also have that Fairfax hat
if you want to get that you know that
canners Delhi
you know Fairfax is that that rodeos
that Rodeo Drive of Judaism you can get
that hat for yourself for anyone use
code hood USA H ood USA for 20% off this
weekend I'll be in Raleigh North
Carolina I'm also coming soon to
Minneapolis Chicago Nashville Toronto
Appleton Wisconsin and a few other
places you can get all the tickets at
Theo von dot-com slash tour tou are also
do you like animals some people do some
people don't
well we're doing an episode coming up
about animals so if you have an
experience that happened with an animal
it could be a thing where maybe you you
know you had an animal and something
crazy happened you had an animal and
maybe I'll took things to like a unique
level you know emotionally or
spiritually maybe you had an animal that
saved your life maybe you had an animal
that you caught an animal trying to do
something sneaky with your child if you
haven't it's an amazing experience that
happened with an animal hit the hotline
don't hit the hotline and just say look
I got a snake his name is you know
[ __ ] Reginald I don't care about that
I need a real experience that happened
with you and an animal the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and now today's episode is
really just a superb human he does a lot
of new stuff he's got a great new
podcast called inside of you
he also played Lex Luthor in in
Smallville on television ladies and
gentlemen mr. Michael Rosen back
[Music]
thanks man I just got up bro really
mucking had been sleeping that gutter
let's go out to China so we rollin bud
all right cool
um dude thanks for coming in today yeah
it's exciting yeah it seems like it was
a little uh I wouldn't say messy yeah
but it seems like I walked in the first
thing you said was you look like [ __ ]
yeah which was was that true was that a
true statement I mean first of all move
the mic down a little bit you're hiding
behind the mic Oh coach is a novice
novice podcast yeah my bad okay second
that I think you look like [ __ ]
how do you think you look well I thought
this is just a podcast I thought you
know we're working a video it's iwata I
brought my cutoff sweatpants and LeBron
shirt that hasn't been washed Wow and
Leona LeBron wagon well no see I'm one
of those guys who just I don't really
know anything about basketball I
couldn't name five players but I like
LeBron you know people give him [ __ ]
yeah I don't talk sports by the fact
that he was in Cleveland moved just to
get a championship came back to
Cleveland won a championship then came
out to LA yeah at the end of your career
you've done everything why not play for
the Lakers yeah you know and I live here
so be fun to see him so yeah I'm right
Bagon puckett did now who was also on
the wagon is who Michael Rapaport is he
on the wagon or he hates LeBron does he
run Hassan Ali runs out here well I'm a
Knicks fan and we just we have nothing
to root for you guys put all that money
on carmella oh yeah I just tears not a
champion well he's just not a team
player
right yeah that's what I felt yeah oh
yeah it was disconcerting to watch that
those years you and you're a hockey guy
right big hockey fan yeah yeah yeah I
love hockey oh I think know about sports
you saw that like cuz recently the lost
Vegas night right yeah that's right
we're about a half an hour not a high
kick now I grew up in Louisiana we
didn't have number one time we got some
ice and time you got ice everybody used
it yeah
people use to keep me cold and
everything like that and I was there if
you do been caught skating on that dude
somebody would've be
your ass her ass bullet would have just
been treason you know would have been
high treason actually you know skating
on a just you know such a usable good
well I grew up in Indiana southern
Indiana we had like there was there's
like a rank or two so that's where I
started playing hockey so I guess when
you get down to that Midwest you can
still maybe get an occasional ring yeah
Indiana once you get down in Louisiana I
think yeah you're right I don't I don't
really know a lot of people that play in
Louisiana
yeah a lot of NHL players from Louisiana
right but uh yeah we were close
relatively close to Michigan couple
hours Chicago Ohio cold cold states
Chicago is not a state but it's a city
did you feel but it could be a state it
could be you know what I'm saying
depends also if you have a mentally
handicapped friend who doesn't know that
much and he might think it's a stage for
sure for sure that theme-park some
people think it's a theme park the car
goes a theme park yeah yeah I don't know
yeah I'm from La Crosse Wisconsin oh
really
yeah I love Shia town that's a cold
place man very cool I'm here yeah those
people yeah they get cold over there
there's a lot of premature baby country
too you know that premature baby country
yeah I think that was just afflicted me
what is premature baby
the CEO is convinced I'm a premature
baby and I just say that I don't know my
biological parents that well so it's
quite possible so you think you just
came out too soon yeah at least smoking
during pregnant and pregnancy he seemed
like he just got here early sometimes I
feel like I yeah I I feel that about
yourself right now really just I didn't
sleep well last night my dog was moving
around yeah I just kind of feel out of
it I think I might have in the bed with
the dog I do sleep in the bed with the
dog and I you know some reason every
night I think you know what this night
I'm gonna have him sleep outside of the
door and he's gonna sleep outside of the
room I'm going to get some good sleep
but there's something about it now that
I I need his warmth now do you start to
worry at that like over replaced because
you're not married right no now do you
worry though that that like you know
that say whatever like vibe you were
gonna like say your instincts we're like
thinking oh it would be nice to have a
woman here that you fill those with the
dog and then you end up not you know
like it's just less of a push to get
married I mean if you even want to or to
have a I don't know the dogs 10 which is
70 real
and I've been dating this girl for like
six months and she likes the doll she
does but she needs sort of needs the dog
on the bed - maybe it's her safety net -
it's like oh he's here but I kind of
need the dog to balance things out it
also separates us a little so you don't
have to cuddle or no [ __ ] like that you
know the dog in the middle yeah and the
dog just gets there you're like alright
[ __ ] off for a while you know yeah but I
like datin a woman who doesn't always
have to be always be so attached oh yeah
I think touching Nexus is touching me
somebody while you sleep sometimes can
be really bizarre I think it's rude yeah
if you're sleeping don't you know
there's no reason to touch so you know a
lot of countries don't do it it's really
an American thing is it yeah you don't
see people in France doing that oh the
French are who gives a [ __ ] what they do
I feel like but it's like if you go to
some other real countries I think real
countries you don't the only reason yeah
yeah look the only reason France isn't
gone is because people are you know kind
of trying to be patient with them but I
think that um that if you go to some
real countries yeah do you go to Russia
you go to like Nigeria Senegal these
people are not sleeping next to nuts not
hugging at night it's almost the same no
hug someone and also be asleep at the
same time when you think about that yeah
that's really weird some people need to
hold onto people to fall asleep are you
are you a cuddler do you do you have a
girlfriend now um I have it yeah I've
got a girl it up it yeah I got a girl
that I've been seeing and we what we do
not sleep on the same bed you know you
sleep well we sit on the same bed while
we sleep in separate realms of it yeah
like I roll over I'm facing the wall she
faces the wall on the other side yeah I
think that's really important it's like
give me my space yeah I like throw I
punched her in the face the other night
inadvertently mm-hmm I just rolled over
for a stretch in the middle of night and
bam and I just are you a hard stretcher
I'm a harder puncher well I just was one
of those things where I felt so bad I
didn't I'd never punched a girl and you
know we did out of a cold sleep and then
you hit oh yes like oh my god punched
you in the face angry yeah [ __ ] that
yeah the dog wasn't there
time see that shows you I need the dog
there yeah I was actually sharing a bed
with a friend of mine and we were just
sharing a hotel room a buddy and then we
each met some girls one time and we were
all sharing beds in New York and out of
a day I was in a dead sleep just na and
I like punched like actually punched it
this girl that was with me he almost had
checked in here not named I mean she was
of age everyone was of age and we uh
and I palm and I like punched her I woke
up and I had punched like it is you no
reason no were you drunk
it would no it was a scary just skimmed
scary dream or something happened and
she was rushed and dude and she had a
straight cranium on her bro
she had a [ __ ] you know from like the
temples up she was like Buster Douglas
you know so do me a favor he had a real
top piece he'd definitely woke her up
you know do you feel bad she was like I
think I've to go pee that was it that's
right strong woman could take a look and
they honestly Mamie and I and I don't
mean like it made me like almost felt
like wow like that this is a real tough
lady yeah you need a tough woman in your
life
dude I had a woman one time in Brazil
put her hand in my in my pocket to steal
my money right and this is a dark one I
guess she was she was in America it
would say a black woman in Brazil I'm
not sure if it was you know sometimes
people say like and you know it's
different kind of colors different
connotation different vibe or whatever
but she looked like a kind of a black
woman in America and she put her hand in
my pocket on all my money was pulling it
out and so I take my other hand and like
pin her hand against my side and then
she's still trying to do it and so now
I'd pull my hand out of my own pocket I
have her hand pinned against my side and
we're punching each other with our lose
hands I mean this woman you're trading
blows with this woman from Brazil and
she was a [ __ ] man in the face yeah
and the neck I mean bro yeah she was
gonna steal shoot her stolen anything
she woulda stole my she would anything I
put in her hand she was gonna steal or
didn't put in her hand cuz I didn't yeah
why would you want to do that I wouldn't
and she was stealing everything and man
I felt like I was getting stolen from
and you just changed like exchange blows
with your opposite hand your loose hand
yeah and it's harder than you think like
if you have like one of your hands kind
of pinned against Ross that one's
crossed yes I do one of these these
little yeah that's a weird way to fight
someone yeah that should be on TV those
matches yeah one arm nice Morissette
fight one hand in my pocket yeah just
another in your neck do the Alanis
Morissette's fights yeah what do you
think yeah dude I'm into it I'm into it
I love that man that's a great idea
what would be another cool sport to
start um you ever think about something
like that yeah another sport [ __ ] man
there's something we need a new sport
you know what sport do you think is
gonna go something naked
I'd love like to see be like naked and
afraid is such a big thing now you
people love that show imagine you're
doing a sport like naked you don't like
that idea
yeah uh I don't is there something
playing sorry I just kept hearing
something um if they do I like naked I
like a naked and afraid but you're that
I think that's fighter in the guy oh
could be um do you uh but if I had to
pick a sport here's my question do you
thought sport do you think is gonna
disappear first that's what I wonder cuz
I don't know if all of these four it's
gonna stay afloat forever you know these
balls definitely gotten boring it's
gotten boring but I think it's gonna
just it's just so Midwest so Universal
you know well I'm gonna say Universal
but just for it's America you know it's
like people think you know football with
all the injuries and the head injuries
and they lost a lot I mean it I don't
know if that will ever go away but now
it's getting more and more dangerous so
right I mean they're gonna take fighting
out of hockey I don't [ __ ] I don't know
that everybody say you know what's funny
is everybody who loves soccer says
soccer is gonna be the biggest sport in
the world it is the biggest sport and
look is the World Cup right but so every
four years you have to hear how that's
the best sport in the world I don't
agree with that and then you don't hear
about it anymore four more years in
America I mean
I think in the rest of the world yeah
it's great I mean I think the World Cups
amazing I love I watch those mini games
I could yeah I don't worry soccer the
second I turn American soccer it's not
appealing at all to me yeah and I just
like a sport where there's more goals
scored yeah I just don't want to watch a
there's 90 minutes and nothing's
happened well that guy fell down again
yeah it's competitive and fun in the
World Cup yeah American soccer I don't
know I would like to watch a guy who's
like texting around on his wife but also
living with her like in the same house
you know what sneakily texting other
women I think if you go by fake it
that's a sport it is it's definitely one
of the most popular sports in America I
wish that they had a way to make it like
a way that we could keep score at home
and like watch it you know I feel like I
wonder if more natural things that we do
as humans if we just videotape those you
know what I'm saying since it's gonna be
more like we're getting into the end of
the time where everything is video a
Truman Show comes should we're just all
the time right and then somehow within
those idiosyncrasies or behaviors of
humans become like a sport you know what
I'm saying yeah I think that could be
kind of cool because I think a lot of
guys probably do that a lot of women do
that yeah you know they're like acting
like their lives are great bouncing
around the house and secretly texting
some right yeah you've never done that
you seem like a good guy you wouldn't do
that oh no man I've struggled a lot man
I've struggled a lot with that kind of
stuff did it stuff harsh eating yeah
you've struggled with cheating yeah I've
never been good at word about you never
been good at cheating you're never been
a cheater I've been a cheater I've never
been good at cheating
I've been good at it but it never ends
well in the end it it's I've never been
good at it because it makes me feel like
a bad person but I'm unable to like it's
not do it I'm saying yeah it's it's a
tough one I've never believed it or not
never cheated Wow and I haven't been
I've been in some relate but yeah it's
tough for me I just can't live with
myself like you said that I'm just not
good at I just feel so horrible well I'm
why would I do this yeah you know
there's even like you know some girl
gave me your number like years ago and I
was dating this person she goes hey
calming she's so pretty and I was like
ah yeah and then afterwards I took her
number I delete it like oh my god what
did I do because I felt like this is you
know this I shouldn't be doing this
the girl doing this to me I don't know
I'm weird like that yeah there's a lot
of it you're not girl I gotta mean
that's a right way to do it yeah and
it's also like a balancing even like
when you're dating man if you ever
noticed this when you're dating it's
like you always have you know it
especially when you're in your 20s or
30s how old are you now I'm a 37 38
yeah I'm 46 are you really I can't be
doing this [ __ ] so you said let you look
like [ __ ] I probably look better now you
look better now because I don't look for
maybe 40 but like for me early 40s maybe
you look better now that when you came
in the room right woken up a little bit
yeah oh good that's a treat by the end
of this you could look [ __ ] really
good like I look 40 grad pity throws at
me why would Brad like Brad Pitt on your
picture of the past weekend with Theo
von that's a really handsome picture you
are a handsome guy I'm an eight bro got
a big nose and my eyes are kind of
little to polish my dad my friend Dax
said I was an 8 he says you're a 6 and
looks and a tenant personality so you're
a solid 8 yeah that's cool eights the
one to get it's universal you know it's
kind of it's filled out like you know I
think eights kind of know some of the
strengths and other weaknesses 10 seem
imagine being a 10 nah can't do it
because you're all going one way yeah
down oh you're Dan you're only going
down let's what I feel like all these
hot guys like Bradley Cooper and you
know yeah they're gorgeous so there's
like a llama a little bit though he
looks like it's like kind of a strong
llama strong mom a good-looking long but
I'm saying he's long and you know it's a
little too long you know really think so
you know what the thing is is if he's a
10 now you only got one way to go for us
guys like us well you're a better
looking me I'm like it but I feel like
hey when I get older I'm not maybe I'll
look a little better or I won't you
won't here's the difference you won't
notice when I start to look worse right
as you will somebody who's really
good-looking right when they get a
little worse everybody know what
happened to Bradley Cooper yeah oh god
he really fell off and all he did was uh
you know he has a little bit of jam on
his cheek from breakfast some Jam all it
was was a little Jam and he's just going
downhill we have jam on our cheek yeah
cute you feel like oh god look at that
back you got yes Schmucker bunny
you know it's true yeah that's my theory
on oh well dude that you know I love
that that is the best thing about being
an eight it's like you have room to grow
you have room to flow kind of a little
bit you know what I'm saying you have
the potential you could show up and be
an eight and a half at a wedding you
know I'm trained he's throwing a suit
Theo von yeah and you're kicking close
to an eight and a half nine yeah but you
clean up real well no I don't think that
but I think that you can look like I
love this so I love the I love the idea
that everybody should think that they're
an eight because here's what I also
think is that you know like like your
buddy Dax told you that you have that
you're a ten and personality and a six
and looks right and if his calculations
could be off due to they could be you
know pretty correct but the thing is is
that it's great to have like we all even
out it's all [ __ ] evens out dude so
it's like like somebody that's rich
could be a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] right
yeah somebody that has one arm could
have a huge dick right somebody that has
somebody that can't read could be Rain
Man you know it so everybody has their
strengths is what you're saying yes
right but it's all and in the end if
you're able to get a complete look at
somebody it all evens out so I think
everybody is an eight really well nice
you to say that I think everything mix
in a was it Nick he could do it too but
he was born early yeah your premature
baby maybe a six but if I was full-term
I'd be an eight yeah the thing he'll
live probably 80 years he'll never hit
nine months you know what I'm saying
he'll live 80 years but it'll never be a
right dial journeymen yeah yeah he's
like Sam Perkins or whatever of like
genetics was your mom a STONER or
anything like that she was all those
things well my mom was my mom was on
valium and a lot of drugs and things
like that a lot of drugs and also
schizophrenia oh wow schizophrenia yeah
yeah you should see this documentary
called three identical strangers that's
out right now it's pretty [ __ ] up
looking for Nick Davis if you look at
premature dude how where is the
premature baby documentary and how that
all plays out
I wonder how that affects children yet I
follow you around Chris today just for
the day I just want to see what your
life's like all right I'm gonna be here
for the next 12 hours you think that you
have like any of that stuff like your
mom's gets a friend she really
schizophrenic she really is and I've
totally like they always say like 30s
kind of like this point where it's safe
and I've always kind of taken self
inventory been like am i [ __ ] crazy
right now but I think I'm cool yeah I'm
all right yeah yeah and so and now once
you get through the 30s and you're safe
of of having like a the onset of it or
know that that's like all the literature
says I mean I'm sure there's anomalies
that happen later 30s but everybody says
late 20s you're kind of you kind of safe
what are signs I just want to know what
signs are so if we see any in the next
30 45 minutes in here with you know
hearing voices well we have you heard
that you're right I might not even be
producing this pocket also delusion
delusions of grandeur okay I'm sitting
in a room with Michael Rosenbaum and to
Yvonne right now I don't think so is
that is that anything like borderline
personality schizophrenia that is I'm
not a psychologist or line personality
disorder uh-uh-uh-uh-uh it'd be great to
have a guess on that has this we could
talk about that though you don't have
any issues um what do I have I think I'm
probably a little bit on the autism
thing somewhere you know outside of that
what else a TV yeah I think every
tension deficit disorder trying to think
of what else outside of that depression
yeah probably depression what else you
said nothing and we've already made
three those to me or blood like those
are like blessings well they're just
ease those are like people have real
[ __ ] it yeah yeah yeah yeah and also
America is like so it's almost like we
get into this creature comfort like it's
almost like having a disease has become
like a creature comfort in a weird way I
think you're right man it's like almost
like you know and I feel like that like
it's it's nice in a way that everybody
could express like hey I have depression
or I have this and that's that's a good
thing but I feel like yeah now we're
seeing everybody's got something wrong
yeah everybody's got it but isn't that
warming isn't that like kind of like
a nice thing - not that I want wish
people bad writings but to know that
everybody's got their [ __ ] so it makes
you feel like hey I'm um I'm not worse
than anybody all right everybody's
struggling everybody's got the [ __ ]
right so that's good it's good to know
the hey you have a little depression I
have a little depression you little
anxiety
ya get anxiety oh you give anxiety
attacks I'm not used to get a more when
I was younger I don't get them that much
anymore yeah you know but it's nice now
he has schizophrenia you know you've got
a little [ __ ] going on I got [ __ ] we're
human yeah no I think it's look I try to
live in that space that you know I feel
like I feel like the one place I feel
like well Hollywood's done a bad job of
acting like people are human you know
it's like they create this idea that
people aren't and then they just use
those elements to like kind of sell
stuff or to you know I don't know I feel
like there's a lot of Hollywood
celebrities who are kind of stuck in a
way like they missed like they got a
there in this old world where they can't
just be themselves yeah and then there's
like another generation that's just like
oh I'm just being whatever I want to be
that kind of is like kind of like
instagramers in youtubers those people
that are just kind of making their own
way they don't really need Hollywood as
much right anyway that's one thing I
just kind of noticed in the industry
yeah but I think it's important like I
mean it's funny because you know you're
coming on my podcast yeah and that's
what I didn't even know what I was gonna
do with the podcast but that's what it
turned into it it became therapy for me
and then it'd be in therapy with the gas
and then people were listening going hey
these people are talking about real [ __ ]
just like about anxiety and all this
stuff I think that's what's like it kind
of it's important to see like
everybody's got their [ __ ] yeah you all
have our [ __ ] oh yeah well we're just
broken I mean we're all broken yeah
we're not well you know but I also think
that it I do believe or I'm starting to
believe and not could be totally wrong
is that it's like there's this thing
where you you get so comfortable as a
country like I was just in China the
other day this past week and those
people don't seem like they're thinking
about that kind of [ __ ] everybody's
doing stuff everybody's cruising and
moving forward it just seems like
everybody's in the past or [ __ ] not
rip in China they're ripping off the
rearview mirror moving forward there's
yeah and it's seen
like we're kind of like in this place
where it's like you can dawdle like you
can be taken care of by the guy like
it's like there's just so many like
there's telev there's like fibromyalgia
which is remembers a television disease
it started it's not real you don't think
that's real what you don't think that's
real
what is it from snakebites what the [ __ ]
is it from dude I don't know chronic
fatigue yeah sure that's hard I got five
or magog a good look if you've seen 600
episodes of [ __ ] prices right yeah
you're always tired I've probably seen
quite a few you know I'd like to buy a Z
that's all you're doing
[ __ ] get I think God Isis right
that's Wheel of Fortune yeah but you
know what I'm talking about you know
what you're talking about
Zach you're talking about it's so [ __ ]
true man hey I think that you just
nailed it man I hate to say cuz people
are out there listener who had that I
thought you said people out there going
hey people know the difference between
prices right in the we love for the [ __ ]
are you talking about but yeah I like
that idea
that moving forward because I think you
know my therapist once said he stood up
in front of me with his generalism in
front of my face oh yeah yeah yeah not
naked genitals it was the rage over on
Santa Monica and he stood over me goes
Michael you've got one foot in the past
you got one foot in the future and he
grabbed his genitals go then you're
pissin on the present Wow and I thought
that was incredibly profound sans the
genitals in the face but I really felt
like you know he's right it's so simple
that's so simple everybody's always
worried about oh my god Marcia she cuz
she told people I was the [ __ ] yeah or
oh my god your your brother is an
[ __ ] he's like 20 years ago this
happened everybody's always thinking
about all this [ __ ] or oh my god I just
need money I just need this I need this
to be happy and we all do it yeah we
need all these things that we don't have
or worried about the future what's the
what's the past the past is [ __ ] me
and if you just try and there's a lot of
[ __ ] right now going on with meditation
and and by the way it's great it's great
like I never did I always look down on
it I was like meditation yeah [ __ ] I
don't need to meditate I wake up I'm
like 15 minutes you just take my
onca way all the other [ __ ] just sort of
be here yeah and it's weird and that
[ __ ]
it does helped it's hard to be present
it's really hard to be present yeah I
think it's you know it's funny I'll sing
about this last night like it's hard to
be present like especially now I think
our phones are something to take us out
of you're still present just gonna say
it but you're into like a different
packet you know it's kind of like your
Reaper it's like you're being repurposed
or repackaged or your yeah your
attention is being taken out of your
presence so it's like you're still
present but your attention is limited
yes well how about this how about how
many times you think that we're talking
right now if we weren't on this there'd
be sort of uh I don't know a propensity
to just kind of grab your phone like you
know we you're with your girlfriend
you're with your friend like yeah man so
yeah how's work going so pretty good oh
cool man yeah I'm glad you finally got a
job that's so cool Rob yeah but um yeah
and then you're on your phone it's
almost like you're compelled to just
you're always thinking about I gotta get
a check what do you what do we have to
check what's the we got an email five
seconds later yeah somebody said I might
miss something why they're like what if
I miss you know what if something
happens the reality is this what
happened in the 80s and 90s dude I miss
that I really do I'm not knocking
technology but don't you just I remember
when my friend Danny cut a recall I
still remember his number eight one two
eight five three six four six four and
you guys can call that actually you can
call it you can call it and ask for the
lated I shouldn't given you that number
the hidden live there anymore he doesn't
for families later but you can still
call anything you got still ask for
Daniel cutter and say is he there and
they don't like hidden leaf anymore
lucky he used to yeah and say if you see
I'm telling them meet me at Newburgh
cinema 8:00 p.m. we're gonna see last of
the Mohicans yeah we're gonna see pink
Cadillac yeah doozy and that's what we
did and you just hoped he'd be there
yeah you thought hey Danny's gonna meet
me there at 8:00 and it's gonna be
alright yeah and you have to check your
text every 10 minutes to see if he's
gonna cancel or he just showed up at
Newburgh Civitan and right and then your
attention was you were excited about
seeing him so it's like your attention
was like you're like oh yeah where's my
buddy you're thinking about the movie
you know your your attention
your focus are in those things whereas
like yes just like our focus gets taken
away for a little bit that's the that's
the thing so it's like you know it's um
I don't know yeah like waters down it
waters it waters everything down in a
weird way it's like yeah I know I'm
gonna see my sister but I've already
talked to her five times this week er
I've already texted with her 20 times
this week it's like it's just not the
same you know yeah maybe there's
something something we can do like I do
a thing where we're having breakfast or
something with my friends and we're
sitting there and I go hey everybody's
cell phone in the middle hmm ever put
their cell phones in the middle
mm-hmm if you want your cell phone
you're paying for breakfast if you grab
your phone you're paying for breakfast
let's all have an hour where we just sit
here and talk to each other yeah and I
think that's you know that's I couldn't
see that how do you breakfast you
probably in silence sometime you do it's
all I know
yeah you don't have to but as long as
you're present as long as you just look
and eat your food and you're there
you're not distracted by anything other
than the food but that's okay that's
I'll deal with that if Theo just wants
to have his food I was thinking the
other day I was thinking yesterday man
so you know we all have family members
that have passed away or whatever my dad
passed when I was kind of young maybe 16
not super young but I was thinking
yesterday I was like man I would it be
nice to see my dad right to spend time
with them but then I started thinking
but how long would I hang out with my
dad before I'd be like man dad I'm gonna
go do something I'm playing out Birds
yeah I'm gonna go [ __ ] like how long
before you hanging out with somebody you
haven't seen your whole life you would
give anything to see it to spend time
with and then you saw them and then how
long do you [ __ ] peek at your phone
oh I'm so great you're so glad you're
alive I just want to check the down oh
my god we're down 40 I'm gonna call my
business manager real quick yeah yeah
you know what it's great but it's crazy
to think that's a crazy thought because
you think oh my god I'd spend every
waking hour for the next droney years
right
oh you wouldn't and the reality is too
is I don't see my family that much I see
my mom she lives in Indiana
let me see her once a year for a couple
days to see my dad maybe once or twice a
year he was in New York hmm I don't see
my family very often and you know the
great thing about technology well the
opposite of what we were just talking
about is I can FaceTime and see my
grandfather see my grandmother so you
know see everybody so that is pretty
soon out so now that's significant it is
so that is significant but maybe if I
didn't have it I'd say I have to go
visit them I have to see them maybe I'd
go see them more but maybe this is a
cop-out it's like oh but I'm seeing them
right I'm gonna see them on this phone
here so maybe I don't know man right
like so I wonder if we're gonna start to
evolve into like you're saying it right
now I have to see them right I wonder if
that's hurt there's gonna be some new
turn of phrase or something that's gonna
be actually that I have to actually
spend you know like it you know because
it used to be I can't wait to see my
grandparents but now you visually you
get that like that's been appeased you
know so it's like then what is it going
like virtual reality touching my
grandparents right or is it gonna be to
feel that Grandma
yeah yeah I feel that she's like what
was that that's warm yeah when she comes
in you're like oh wow gram I still come
bro this is we're gonna take this part
out we have alarm started I just was
wondering at Grandma's come I don't know
you kept it going I can't understand a
guy says something every now and then
you know I didn't I just said I just
want it as a question I just like to be
educated there's no stupid questions
look I understand somebody throws a
grenade into a [ __ ] into a I know
into a busy family dinner you know but
you throw it back what's wrong about no
but the guy who picks it up and like
shows it to everybody in the dinner
yeah so everybody's looking at it when
it blows up that's [ __ ] up so I showed
that gone that come grenade to everybody
at dinner is what I did think about my
grandma blance coming either so you're
you're starting to look definitely
better than when you walked in really
yeah yeah I didn't I was asleep you know
I really I was really I'm bummed if I
look like [ __ ] in the beginning I
apologize and I appreciate your honesty
theater but I didn't know cameras I you
know I think Gianni he did we put hockey
together
and I just and I forgot I don't read
things that well I've a DD and I didn't
know there were cameras but I'm okay I
think your audience is probably cool
like this I'm just shorts and a shirt
I'm not gonna wear a suit or anything
I'm out of fancy pants
well some people I think we're also
thinking we come in as a little bit more
of like your superhero attire and also
but Lex Luthor is not a superhero and
he's a super villain he's super villain
oh yeah some people call him the like
the anti hero or I don't know do you
think he had the ability to and for some
of our listeners that don't know Michael
played Lex Luthor on Smallville right
for seven years in seven years it's a
long haul and do you start to feel as
like like so as an actor and as a care
like having a character do you is there
a certain part point like after a
certain number of seasons or episodes or
maybe it's immediate that the character
actually starts to feel more like yours
and you're able to do some things yeah
you know it's weird as it was like I was
always like funny guy and you know I was
doing some comedies at the time I did
with your buddy Harlan Williams I was
taking a hike with Tom Green and Harlan
a couple of weeks ago and they just
randomly go that Theo von man is [ __ ]
funny have you seen his and Tom's like
yeah I'm and they start talking about
you like that's yeah he's a good guy
just I had dinner with him at Bobby
Lee's birthday party in the middle of
nowhere yeah
Harlan so nice I don't know time as well
but yeah but they think the world
Tom's Canadian though and they're so
nice yeah all of them I think all of
them are nice so how did they do it and
living right next to us yeah that's in
there oh and the cold man what was I
saying oh my my I wake up my a sees two
degrees too long [ __ ] furious what
are you keep it on the sleep I'm at 69
are you and I didn't see that lebra
funny well your Hospital Lex Luthor oh
yeah yeah oh so anyway yeah the Lex
Luthor thing you know I was always doing
funny stuff so I got this Raw's like
they're gonna fire me there's no way I'm
gonna play this serious for my friends
like they cast you is this and I shaved
my head and then I started wearing these
suits and I don't you know and it was it
was just did you think it could really
be you in the beginning like we do like
you were you on like because sometimes
you get
is something you're like oh this is I
can do this and then sometimes you're
like maybe they see this maybe they see
something that I don't fully see yet
like was there any other hat or what was
it I was nervous I had a lot of
confidence I gave the best audition of
my life they asked me they go hey be
serious here be dangerous here be funny
here because that's seven hundred other
guys auditioned for and I go what did
seven hundred other guys do they're not
that you want didn't do that you want me
to do and they said well just be
dangerous me so I remember we had three
pages of dialogue I've told the story
but I circled be Chris mattock here be
dangerous here be funny here and I'm
three pages I chose to do that I made
distinct right decisions I
differentiated whatever and I just did
it and I had a lot of confidence because
I really at first didn't want at night
it was like what is this I'm not gonna
get I just for one of it I could be
insecure as [ __ ] I could be I could not
have the the confidence and I did that
day mm-hm
and so when they cast me I was like
they're gonna fire me this is I mean I
can't I can't play this villain I can't
and they shaved my head I looked in the
mirror and I go oh you look different
you little weirder not that bald people
are will but I write weird I looked a
little dick has its own matrix bump on
the back of my head which I still had
not as if it alone and I just looked
different and that helped me transform
the nipa Armani student saw me look at
me I wear t-shirts and sweats and that
that was a problem too when I went out
with women I think they thought they
were dating Lex Luthor didn't loot Lex
loser I don't have a suit I have a
conversion van everyone yeah I just
wasn't you know I wasn't like as cool
and smart as they thought you know this
character was Sammy Luthor they got Sam
Luthor yeah but I just I fell into it I
got comfortable in the dialogue and they
let me start a be myself in a way a
heightened version darker version and
that start to grow over time like we did
you start to because I know sometimes in
the beginning of things they just you
know they want to get things established
like even just as like you know but were
you able as a care are you able to like
create the character more as time goes
on and you know like what little bounds
and things that that character can do on
screen that are still gonna come off
yeah this is the biggest fight for me
was they they were you know it's like
one is here to come EE but I can't
become evil but I could have moments and
I could have like little nuances and
things like
you could say oh there is that dark side
there is that so it was me just trying
to keep in check because I knew I had
six or seven seasons to do it in if the
show was gonna be successful if I got if
I start twirling the moustache but then
I was [ __ ] right like okay is evil
right so it was one of those things like
I call the guys and say hey and they
were great in collaborative we're trying
to work on something now together
Alan miles who created Smallville and
Badlands into the badlands a buncha yeah
yeah they're awesome and they're just
like I was like he isn't this a little
too
menacing he's like you know what we
wrote it but we know you're gonna play a
little against that if I always fight
things so the best thing to do when
you're playing a villain or you're
playing a and I don't know if a lot of
people do this but this the secret is
play the opposite if it just it's if
it's so dark if you play the opposite it
still gonna be dark but it's like you're
not playing into the dark right now the
darkness is like a subtlety of yours
becomes subtle so people will say oh
when he did that with his eye that was
actually a Twitter I don't this really
comes through yeah and so it was fun but
I'm not like a TD like you I kind of got
like I'm after season one I'm like okay
I did this what's the next project well
you got six years left buddy but I I
evolved and and the character you know
became kind of fly and then let me sort
of bounce around ideas and you know
there's episodes where hey I knew I get
too freaked out in this episode because
something happens so I could play this
dark Lex
so I freaking out and being maniacal
there i i i can't you know wes craven
once told me was the best Wes Craven the
murder man the mystery murder mystery
well he's director of Nightmare on Elm
Street yeah mystery murder man yeah well
but he's one of my favorites and I
worked with him and he just say he said
to me you know you're gonna play an
amazing I don't know psycho killer
likeable murderer so like I go well he's
like no this is a good thing in your
career I go well Lex leak is no no no
something else that's gonna happen
because you and it was just a compliment
I just love Wes Craven's my hero and
this is before you're like sooo thick no
this was as I was doing Lex Luthor so
this was something else but I was like I
like to go a little nuts you know in
life you can't really go nuts because
people think you're nuts but ya go nuts
on screen and take all that [ __ ] that
bothers your the [ __ ]
stuff as a child like I you know things
that I resented or things that I
remembered and and channel it through
emotion like on that's yes it's I can I
don't know if it's fun but it's
cathartic and it's real and I noticed
that when I would do it it would get a
rise out of people like I could see the
creators and the show and the people in
the fans would be like oh like I was
like oh because I didn't know freaking
out on screen would delu Zola krill do I
look menacing and write of a [ __ ] in
real life maybe I don't know am i tough
enough like how does this come off yeah
how does this come off but you just
trust it and just went you know some
when the dialogue was there and you
start to see me freaking out in the
early seasons in certain episodes
wearing a straitjacket and going Craig
just going for it I just went for and I
think that's something when you're
younger tells 27 28 29 and I talked
about this in my podcast is like you
know that ambition that I want to do
anything I just want to you know and
then you get older and you start to I
don't know if you lose that beat that
that drive that motivation but back then
I was just like unstoppable I felt like
I [ __ ] it man I'm young and do you ever
feel like when you get older you just
thought you lose that a little bit that
fire yeah I mean I think I did you
definitely lose I lose that's a good
question as I get older what do I feel
like I lose I feel like you're just at
the beginning you're really blowing up
so it's different with you maybe you
like I'm always gonna late bloomer
real me too yeah did you have hair on
your balls in high school probably had a
little I didn't have much until I'm a
junior
Nick really uh I was pretty late I don't
know like yeah eighth grade I mean
obviously prematurely mm-hmm yeah yeah
um started to go to the ball here no
grandma I think it's interesting man
like it's tough these days to like I
think as you as I get older what do I
notice it's different that's a great
question what do I notice that's
different about like like my like like
fervor like my vitality or things that I
would do differently in my 20s that I
wasn't doing my 30s I don't know I felt
like I was so much more like insecure
probably in my 20s and even like in my
early thirties so I feel like more like
I'll I'm a little more in touch with who
I am now I guess so yeah I guess I
wouldn't do as much errant stuff you
know like I wouldn't just throw caution
to the wind and do something kind of
crazy yeah like dude armor one time bro
like they're like you need to sing in
this audition and I'm like I can't even
sing you know I can't sing if we weren't
in an audition right now you know sing
in the shower you don't sing in the car
I mean I'd do a couple of [ __ ] bars
brother but I ain't doing it I'm not I'm
not faking it through a whole song just
to [ __ ] make it through a you know a
you know a moment a conditioner you know
what I'm saying like I'm not a [ __ ]
psychopath so what I I remembered
watching what was it Oh a Shirley Temple
when I was young right on the good ship
lollipop I was like yeah that's a song
you can pull off if you live I just
gotten out to LA I was like Shirley
Temple Hollywood legend you know we're
gonna love this that's how they could do
it you know so my hair a little bit was
sitting there and I can still remember
their faces dude they thought it was a
joke you know and I was like on Bambang
what on a sunny beach and peppermint Bay
you know like and you're serious yeah
then I stopped and then I'm like
crackerjack bands like I had a whole I
went second stanza you know what I'm
saying it shook them
I remember the assistant lady just like
had a straight in her neck out she
didn't know I was gonna go [ __ ]
seconds second stanza a [ __ ] lame
yecch
wherever she is thank you feel yeah you
sitting there judging me the whole time
you were [ __ ] assistant you're not
even doing anything of your [ __ ] you did
take a chance you're asking Shirley
Temple in the middle of [ __ ] Muppet
romance Lascar choked out all your
[ __ ] cousins bro come on your face oh
oh sorry
this guy's tossing dirty grenades and
[ __ ] into the fruit salad um but yeah
I think that's one thing like I think
like Dan I would do that and I have any
thought it's like now I'm like no way
what I did so maybe do you like you know
more stuff and you wouldn't do yeah it's
like you have more frame or reference I
think you know your strengths now you're
like I'm not gonna do that
I can't sing be I'm not gonna embarrass
myself in front of this chancellor's
[ __ ] right and see [ __ ] off
yeah you know I'm just not gonna I can
understand that but I I kind of missed
that but you're right blind ambition
that sort of you know I do I do miss
that you know that sort of like fear I
think still gets in the way and when
fear didn't get it in a way then I mean
we all have a little fear mm-hmm but I'm
you know I'm working on that I'm working
on not giving a [ __ ] more and I think
that's like just being in touch with
myself a little more and sort of saying
hey what do you want what do you want in
life what is it you want mean you've
been doing this you've been acting
people okay what's next what are you
doing that's the question in LA hey what
are you up to guys feel compelled to be
like oh I got a special I got this movie
coming out I'm writing this script I'm
right and doing this you need to tell
people you feel compelled to tell
everybody what you're doing so they
think you're something gives you the
feeling of I'm somebody yeah and I don't
I don't like that I'm not doing that
yeah so when people ask me what I'm
doing sometimes I'm like not a goddamn
thing yeah I'm doing my podcast I'm
playing in my band that's some fun you
have a band you guys are on tour someone
said right well there's a toriaezu doing
dates around the country well we were
called [ __ ] sandwich right now we're
called the sandwich it was just a joke
we were in my basement and we were just
like well my bass player didn't Carl
he's on ballers but all weathers no not
Carl Weathers but he is african-american
cause he really yep
like Carl Weathers is called weathers a
real person Carl Weathers is he was
Apollo Creed oh wow in the Rocky movies
he's a big deal yeah he's a big deal but
Carl bevor played bass he learned to
play bass Kent was playing drums never
Lou played drums I was like who's gonna
sing like you am I I'm not a great
singer so I said [ __ ] it so I started
writing my own songs laughs playing my
friend goes open up for us at the
troubadour Mike what he goes do it I've
never been more scared so I got up we
did three songs original he goes come to
Germany open for me so they paid for our
[ __ ] you went to Germany last year going
to Germany this year I'm playing in the
love Street festival here in Hollywood I
mean we're just rep my own [ __ ] and it's
not it's not complex it's not Radiohead
it's not like but it's like 70 southern
rock meets like gin blossom
wallflowers 90s throwback story but we
play our own [ __ ] and I love it I love
it and I you know it's just fulfilling
yeah whether people love it or not I I
really enjoy it and so like well like
certainly like obviously with having
some success there's something that
happens as you start to get like a
confidence that comes once you start to
have some success in your in your work
world right and I think it's probably in
any work world but it's like you know
would you have got into the band like
you know ten years ago would you have
you know it's like you start to get a
little bit more comfort ability once
obvious you have a little bit of enough
money you can pay your rent you know I'm
saying some of those yeah fixed costs
are kind of taken care of
yeah I did that with it was just you
know sort of bucket list [ __ ] and I was
like you know what I've always wanted to
be a singer I've always wanted not
singing but I always wanted to write
songs and perform them I always want to
do stand-up comedy Harlan was like dude
open for me bud yeah open for me pal
McNab yeah mm people Oxnard no one's
gonna give a [ __ ] get up there give
eight minutes and I got up there and I
[ __ ] did it and I fell in love with
it and then I Bobby Lee's like you're
opening from me in here and I started
did I saw you he's gone up and I had
never done it so I was going up with
these big [ __ ] like you and Rogan and
Bobby Lee and Swartz and it Harlan and I
was in there I'm telling you acting and
all this [ __ ] I've done never been more
[ __ ] up nervous like and the reality
is I should have been thinking dude you
just started this go out there and bomb
have fun not be so hard on yourself you
can't be as good as these guys right
you're not gonna be great and I didn't I
was so excited I'll just
I gotta make someone like I don't I
gotta kill it and I put so much pressure
on myself that I think it drove me
[ __ ] crazy
Wow for six months it drove me crazy
where I was just like at the end of last
year I was just exhausted I was just
like I gotta take some months off and
just like between the music and that and
writing I was just like I'm too hard on
myself I gotta give my body a break Wow
I I think that stems from childhood to
is just being too hard on yourself
you're not good enough insatiable did
you ever have to deal with that yeah I
think I did deal with that kind of stuff
you know I mean I think a lot of it was
just I would get so nervous everything
would to make me
so nervous forever how did you get over
that I think a lot of just a repetition
over time and then I just I think having
some successes starts to make me feel
less nervous overall like starting to
like just realizing okay like I can do
one thing like there's one thing I can
do okay I can do you know stand-up
comedy I can do it so then I start to
live a little bit differently in my body
like I know at least there's one thing
that I know I can do so then it's like
like I don't know I've never had the
feeling before of like something that I
could do you know that I was able to
really do and like felt like I really
could do it and so then I guess it's
some of the then that starts to live in
you differently like oh I can do
something you know and then then I would
go into other things and at least then I
would know okay there will be a point
with this where I'll know that I can do
it you know and then but also you slowly
get start to get to use to a little bit
of what it feels like to be to have some
confidence and so I guess some of that
you know success helps that's you're
right it's like yeah I'm a complicated I
mean we're all calm well do people look
at well it's just a question with
success do people start to look at you
differently if you have a success behind
you right I think they do I remember
like whenever I first got out here loss
handles like oh and Benjamin is a
comedian Nick Thune is a comedian they
hit like the big time like right out of
the gate like they were just like rocket
launched into like they were the next
thing right like MySpace had just come
out and I think there was these rumors I
don't know if this is true I some of it
is true but I don't know how much of it
is that they each got like a half a
million dollars from like MySpace or
Comedy Central to make like some web
series and stuff like that and so
everybody was like holy [ __ ] like that
was half a million dollars like twelve
years ago you know I was like it was
like a million though yeah yeah they
gained in her thousand so so everybody
was like holy [ __ ] these you know these
guys you know this is the thing this is
it
you know [ __ ] I don't know we were
talking about well how'd that make you
feel I mean was that like something what
were you talking about Nick you hadn't
achieved confidence yet you haven't had
success right oh so everybody look at
them Thank You Nick
so everybody looked at them like
suddenly we're like oh these guys know
what they're doing you know this is not
a scary feeling when someone you think
everybody knows what you're doing look I
have a we there's a weird psychology oh
I agree it is I'm the same but it's but
it's interesting to me now looking back
like did they know what they were doing
probably not any more than anyone else
now do they start to feel like they know
what they're doing it would be
ridiculous if they didn't feel that way
because whatever they're doing is
showing is is having a return you know
their achievements the mindfuck what you
just said is it's kind of a mindfuck but
yeah good well I guess I understand it
right it's a weird place to be in so
they probably so then they start to feel
more confident because when they walk in
a room people look at them like you know
it's like these guys know what's funny
they know what they're doing
yeah and what's scary is those sudden
you're out of the loop right and they're
like what do we do wrong how do we get
that now we're not confidence about our
stuff we got to get find something that
makes us confident so people look at
them like like and it's just like
there's this they're uncertain they're
unable they messed up and so yes and
then in the end and that's a lot of that
might just be Hollywood I don't know if
that's like that in other businesses I
think I think maybe it's mostly it's
Hollywood
feels like that I don't know I think
that's probably sports too it's
something like he's the VP out of 340
last year now he's back to 40 uh he's
done his careers washed up he's finished
right you know get rid of him new guy
and then that guy's got to build up and
start taking more batting practice yeah
go get coaching and also he comes back
maybe you know it's it's such a tough
business and like you know it's who's
hot like I heard like some a lot of
people look at your [ __ ] IBD IMDB
number yeah if you're not like in the
top hundred you they don't cast you yeah
you gotta be hot you got to be this how
many followers you have
how many Instagram I don't it's not
about talent anymore right right right
it's not but I think that there are
I believe that the audience that
audience has to get smarter as well in
some ways where I think they do want
I think audience does want something
that's more real and it's more authentic
you know than they did I think they're
tired of just being pushed like I don't
know I feel like there has to be some
you know every day I definitely feel
like everything's changing I definitely
like a lot more of it is in the hands of
the Entertainer now do you feel that at
all or no yeah I feel like it's just
like uh well you came out of studio
shows me you come out of network shows
yeah yeah I like I mean you just had
what was the other was the new show that
you had recently that was uh I was
imposter yes dude everybody's been
telling me to watch that it was phony
only lasted two seasons but I played a
guy who's pretending to be this gay
pastor in the small town but I was
really screwing prostitutes and doing
drugs and it was awesome so a stepdad
basically it was it was awesome and we
did two seasons and we pretty much got
to do what we want and I had a blast it
was it was it was the show that I would
probably done for forever it was just
one of those shows really you're blessed
to be working it's just like you're
working for Munchie bust your ass you're
making comedy every day you're laughing
it's dark it's funny it's a you know
you're getting paid for it it was a
dream job and those jobs are but back to
your point
there's so many things now that you know
when I was I'm not old but like you know
we're younger like think about it how
many studios were there how many
stations were there how many like who
was making TV shows and movie now it's
like YouTube stations and anybody yeah
instagrams doing their own thing and
filming a movie under the desk right now
yeah he's [ __ ] what are you doing ah
yeah I mean it definitely looks like a
lighting but I mean it's like a short
film but you can do whatever you want
the good thing is you can make a movie
with your iPhone you could do whatever
you want you can make product but the
bad thing is there's so much of it now
right it's everywhere and it's hard to
like people say hey there's a new show
I'm like yeah by yesterday I heard
there's a new show right the day before
somebody else said there's
show and there's eight superhero movies
coming out this month yeah and there's
for dressing worlds coming out yeah and
then superhero now it's not a bad it's
just like it's just I don't even know
what to do I'm so a DD and not even the
insect it's a woman whose sister had a
couple of children yeah you know it's
like I just want a [ __ ] chicken or
beef yeah
or vegan even there's three right but
just to me it's so much so many choices
that I don't even have time I I don't
know what to do hmm but you must be
there must be something about you that
finds because you have your own podcast
now yeah and so there must be something
that has led you in that direction to be
it to want to create your own stuff
because I think whether we realize that
in the beginning of having a podcast or
not I think it ends up leading us there
some I mean I don't know what are some
of the stuff you found you I just nailed
and you you insinuated something you
were like you know it's like we why do
we do it and we found is it something
you did you find so that's exactly what
it was at first my producer Rob was like
dude you need to do a podcast and I was
like man I don't think I need a podcast
because yeah you do I think he'd be fun
and just talking to people and I got
alright you know what [ __ ] it how much
does it cost goes get a soundboard we'll
get some mics we'll go to your house
give celebrity friends you have at you
know athletes you have you know people
that rob sounds like a great guy he's a
great guy he's a kid
he said 29 he's got a kid he's married
he's just a nice kid you know so he
hooked the stuff up and I'd invite my
friends over like Swartz and Harlan you
know at first was just like hey you
don't fire them and stuff out about them
but all of a sudden I go it one day I
don't know what it was it was like Zach
Levi was on the guy who's playing Shazam
or you know just Sam Liu that guy's a
I'm the superhero he's they just did a
new movie the guy who knows what music
is huh
that's a [ __ ] superior no you say I'm
a member music app yeah that's a [ __ ]
superhero now no but anyway this guy
tears up for talking I was like
grandmother when I was growing up
somebody could remember a song from the
70s was a grandparent now that's a
[ __ ] superhero
I quit dude is a superhero everybody's
here
asthma's now a superpower some guy that
can't handle air and is gonna die soon
Wow right there now uh but look for me
became therapy I'm telling you man I all
of a sudden talking to somebody and I go
down this rabbit hole where it's like oh
you get anxiety like we're talking about
in there like yeah yeah it was
debilitating and I did this and I'm like
you know finding out Kristen Bell has
suck in anxiety and depression and all
that Jennifer Love you it doesn't love
herself and like really loves her middle
name loves her middle name and she
doesn't love herself and we and all of a
sudden I get these text from her saying
that was like I've never done a podcast
and I was crying the day I'm how happy
it made me to talk about these things
and be open and I was like then I
realized wow I get emails from people in
text and Twitter and and it just made me
feel good that people are it's almost
they listen to it and there's hope for
them yeah I feel like oh this I this was
my idol and she's she's got a problem
she's kind of [ __ ] up we're all [ __ ]
up yeah we were talking about so for me
it inadvertently became like this is
real if I'm just real if I'm just
talking to people and fine and [ __ ] out
and we have fun but laughing but I find
all this dark [ __ ] and the dark yeah
dark like the art stuff tomorrow I'm
interviewing Dave Bautista you are a
wrestler yeah but from guardians of the
galaxy to he was drag so I'm like
excited I want to find out some [ __ ]
yeah about him I bet he's got some dark
[ __ ] yeah and I think that's what people
want to hear they don't they don't want
to hear just like people going though
your movies coming out you know those
late night shows or it's five minutes
yeah it's just flop it's not real well
it's all [ __ ] Muppet tree yeah you
know exactly right how do we choreograph
this to just to make the audience sort
of just laugh he's nice handsome go see
his movie right that's not you know it's
a [ __ ] sham that's what it is at a
certain point
it's Sam it's a Shazam yeah it's a
Shazam just um we got a couple of fan
line questions that came in let's get to
a couple of those Bros huh he's alive no
there's not a lot no missus lot dude
question from Michael you Lex Luthor on
the UH
he was great man and I'm curious where
he thinks a new life worker that Jesse
Eisenberg riddler loser that old goofy
ass Luther I don't like him man take it
easy guys Jesse Eisenberg's playing
Luther
he played him already oh wow I need to
see that um yeah you know that's a
thanks for the question that's hard for
me to answer because it's easy to sound
like a dick like if I was here to sit
here and say oh yeah he really dropped
the ball he he played it maniacally I
wouldn't have done that I think you know
it's like there's a direction and Zach
Snyder was the director of the last
movie right and so he he and Jesse said
this is the character and this is what
you're doing and they worked it
collaborated and that was the Lex Luthor
the Jesse Eisenberg did and you know a
lot of people didn't like it a lot of
people liked it you know yeah I I would
always say like look man it's it's a
vulnerable you know position to be and
it's like you're an actor you do a part
and like people are gonna love you or
hate you or somewhere in between or
forget you and I don't know I I enjoyed
doing Smallville for seven years I loved
playing the character I always thought
Lex Luthor he was like he had his [ __ ]
together and he was more in his head
right and it was real and it was just
like in him when he blew up he blew up
and you were intimidated by him you were
a little scared of him you weren't sure
what he was capable of so that's my
interpretation of character but you know
that interpretation of the character of
eisenbergers someone here that we can
see yeah that interpretation was just
you know it was a different version that
was uh you know so yeah sort of like a
little bit like the Joker a little bit
like crazy maniacal and that was a
direction that it shows so right that I
do on that response um oh I see yeah
there he is and I worked with him and he
was a great guy and he's a great actor
so you know people always say oh well
why don't you play like so they're like
well they didn't ask me did he put on
weight for this at all or no no I don't
think so it seemed like he'd almost be a
little too meek I feel like yeah um yeah
he looks like a Lex Luthor like maybe in
Brooklyn maybe you know I couldn't see
him Lex Luthor about side of that area
ring he looks like a gentrification Lex
Luthor yeah well the good thing is he's
the you know well I don't know like you
know they're going from you know they
went Jewish for Lex Luthor with me
Rosenbaum then I went to Eisenberg so I
don't know so it's obviously Jewish is a
Jewish thing
no Eisenberg Rosenbaum who's next fall
yeah that's Vaughn's on a Jewish name
does um so what was another question
what do you have Nick oh yeah we got
another question here
another Smallville one oh yeah hey
what's going on question for Michael
Rosenbaum I don't know too touchy but
what was what's the deal well on the set
of small dog show used to go with
Allison back did he get the vibe or
anything that she was in some freaky sex
cult [ __ ] oh yeah I'm crazy stuff you
bring a picture he like the vibe there
will receive she beard but but this was
settled my field anyways man you're the
man every day man is I haven't responded
to this look at this so Allison Mac is
the girl what was this thing called I
remember they busted a man who was
running who was using a group here you
go
you know I've sure you know it's funny
cuz I've chosen not to talk about it
only because it's so it's shocking and
all I could say is this when I was on
that show Allison was the sweetest
professional most professional she was
just a great girl great actress and you
know I remember you know that being
doing some self-help stuff
I remember she's a part of something and
it was a different than it was now by
remember her mentioning something oh
there's a agape or some organization or
something no there's always there's a
lot of those whatever I didn't let me to
it I just remember thinking oh it sounds
a little cool T I'm yeah I'm not it's
not for me I don't I don't know and I
just never thought about it but it never
she never sorry I bet this is the first
time I've actually talked about it but I
felt like it was such a shock to hear
all these things I just didn't believe
it right you know it's like somebody
said hey your brother killed somebody
no he didn't I know my brother he
wouldn't kill anybody right so yeah
seeing this it's still it's a little
it's bizarre it's like you know I want
to hear that you know the whole story I
thinks yet to come out but I think a lot
of the story is out there now and
I think it's just shocking it's
surprising she was great I just bumped
into an old director from small then we
looked at each other like you know
things happen in life in your like you
just don't have answers for and for me
it was like working with someone for
seven years we weren't we didn't go out
we didn't like did you ever ask her so I
hung out with Tom a little bit and you
know I wasn't around Tom Welling he was
Superman they were sad for Kent so I
hung out with him so I really didn't
hang out with Allison but maybe a couple
times throughout seven years was they
didn't know each other we weren't close
friends but like there was always a
mutual respect and a love there did you
ever hit on her was there anything like
that no never never never I never with
any of my coasters never would do that
yeah you don't [ __ ] where you eat
although I have shat where I
yeah you know yeah in the in the past I
mean there's when I was younger I did a
movie in Germany and the girl and I the
actress and I we we kind of got to get
it was a mistake but then we became
friends eventually which those just
never end well so I never understand
what people do that because no matter
what if you're on a show maybe a movie
at the end something because the movies
over but a TV show it's just bad bad bad
idea man right it's just not good so I
and the good thing is is Annette O'Toole
was like older than me and married so
you know that wasn't there and you know
Kristen and Alison were a lot younger
than me right but that's attractive to a
man it's like yeah but it was they they
felt like you know younger sisters okay
I was 25 and they were 18 and what was
her vibe like I mean was she like you
were 25 and they were 18
that's nothing sane at all that's well
maybe I was 26 yeah even if you're 36
that's not that look you know what it
was it was just like they're on the show
they're younger I don't have as much in
common I like the seventies music I'll
I'm partying at that time they're like
going to museums they're smarter than I
am okay I've got a nerdier there maybe a
little nerdy er but just maybe more
intelligent okay although you know I
don't know maybe more in Tel Aviv me
more mature than I was which is not not
hard to do right so I just didn't go
there I thought it was a bad idea
not to say I never talked to a guest
guest star ever you know if we became
friends but just never do anything on
set right like later on if you become
friends and you're the guest stars over
like a
coffee right working on the show anymore
but in hindsight like oh there any do
you think do you think you could see her
so do you could you see her like being
and getting into something like that no
never never I thought she was just a
girl a nice person who just you know
she's like a lot of actresses or actors
you know we want attention we want
approval and she found something that
she thought would probably you know give
her that and then and I don't think
that's what she was doing when I when I
knew her writing this was years ago but
ultimately inadvertently she got into
something that was bigger than her and
you know I'm hearing things like you
know she said supposedly that you know
it was a manipulation or it was like you
know she was what's the word coerced
Stockholm Syndrome type of stuff I I
just I think that she you know she know
who's to say what happened I mean I'm
not a so nobody know we don't know I
don't know all I know is you know what
we can it's it's shocking that it
happened like if you said off the Yvonne
killed someone I'd better oh yeah
because I don't know you as well and
maybe you did kill someone's not
shocking but when you're who is it that
you'd what who did I kill
I mean you could have killed someone oh
yeah yeah you probably could have hiding
someone you probably had killed that
girl that the african-american woman had
put their hand in your pocket in Brazil
oh yeah my hunch is brough did it would
have taken a while doing some very weak
punch it killed you though
Oh easily easily she probably could and
the crazy thing was people around us in
Brazil started like cheering and like
betting on who was gonna win because we
both had long hair row we're both out it
was broad daylight nobody helped people
started literally you're scared
batting I was extremely scared I was a
very walking in a foreign country by
myself and not even in like the best
area it was it was [ __ ] affecting my ego
yeah like I would have thought like out
of all these people this woman thought I
was weak enough to put her hand in my
pocket oh gosh oh yes I got a workout or
something well you know what right after
that I went back on like I was on a [ __ ]
I was on a cruise ship and went back
onto the cruise ship and stayed on there
I didn't go
back out into the concept shame I felt
like unwelcome I felt
yeah just scared you know I did feel
like some of that kind of with some of
them something like that when someone
violates you yeah it's just it's it
ruins everything I begin by the hell for
and nobody helped you know that was that
is bad gambling on some who's gonna
[ __ ] win more gambling yeah and then
also I remember this in Brazil
somebody would come up to you and say I
have AIDS right it was a kid I have AIDS
I'm gonna bite you unless you give me
money that was I would have stayed on
the ship it was a good call feel that
was the aids bite trick you guys do that
in nightclubs here in LA all the time
but it's like this is like you know oh
and bite you I'm gonna take a bite out
of your wallet take me to Mel's Diner
yeah yeah that's not good
that ain't fight boy yeah but um so you
never saw anything like that with that
so you would never think that every girl
would be innocent never I thought she'd
be married with kids and she was she was
smart she was you know family was in the
music and opera and stuff and sort of
upper-class I just well so how does that
happen oh that you know what that means
but I just you look at her like oh you
know she's got her stuff together she's
she's not an idiot with her money and
she's I just right thought it I don't
think any of us thought so then how does
that happen then I think that you just
you don't ever really know someone you
don't ever really really know someone
like I could tell you my friend Tom of
32 years friendship I promise you he
would never kill someone yeah but that's
because I've grown up with him since I'm
12 years old right I know him inside out
her no that's Daniel cutter yeah Tom
Lally
like I've seen his penis I'm not in a
gay way no but you know we know each
other I've been in the hospital he's
taking care of me when I had back
surgery he's like you know he's like
more of a almost getting in a gay way
taking care no no he's just my best
friend and he sounds like Bridges of
Madison County almost
maybe it does to the I know but you're
right I should have stopped with the
penis and he didn't have to take care of
me yeah penis right like we're like
trying on scars yeah it wasn't good it
wasn't good okay see your friend Tom I
could tell you so I'm gonna change the
way I thought I'm gonna do a trump there
I'm gonna like change like the wood and
wooden thing but I think that he
wouldn't kill someone I know him but
when you say Allison what'd she do this
I didn't know Allison right I probably
you know I'd see her once a week and I
go hey what are you doing how's your
weekend great
who's this past weekend with Theo von
and it that would be it and I'd be like
oh my god yet dinner out great herbs me
the makeup trailer it's like what you
guys listening to and that was it I
directed at her in an episode she was
sweet as hell and she's like oh I need
to cry can you tell me that nice story
about your grandma I would tell her the
story and she would cry then she we'd
roll camera and she was just sweet she's
nice I didn't expect this this is a
curveball but again I didn't really know
her okay well then how about this then I
have did she seem like a sexual person
at all because you know some of the
things that they got caught on these
you're going deep man well no I'm just
curious about the psychology of some of
this type of stuff because this kind of
stuff is you know it's like look like
I'll have for example I will have people
that will reach out to me right like you
might have chicks that are like porn
stars different types of stuff reach out
to you or women that wanted text you can
get you in like I've had yeast have this
girl don't invite me to like these
orgies and stuff down Joe no I didn't go
but here's the thing it's like it would
have just been but I met up with her one
time for coffee right so it would just
so there's just a couple of you know it
could be a couple of weekends it could
be a drug of some drug it could be a a
couple of drink um it you're only a few
steps away sometimes from things that
you don't think you would be in right
but I think you would still like some
people would still have a vibe in them
that would you know that would that
would match the current of whatever that
that is yeah I feel like she had like a
sexual type of vibe really
was like a you know some disease like in
cells now there's people that are afraid
of sunlight and are just lazy and you
know aren't doing sex or people that you
know no one likes him so they just say
that no one wants some you know I think
you know look did she seem sexy did she
seem sex I mean that's you know I began
I thought of her as like a kid I didn't
look at her like that but I I just you
know you know she was like everybody
else she was flirty she was fun she was
nice I didn't really see that side of
her I just didn't see it yeah yeah but I
didn't hang out with that but I will say
this I think that like for me all a bit
of a control freak in terms of like
drugs and alcohol like right like I have
friends who get drunk and they're like
they shouldn't drink and they get so
hammered that remember things and like I
don't want to be that person yeah I am
always aware of what I'm doing
I don't put myself in precarious
situations right I just don't I
I can sense bad things happening yes
it's always been it's a gift but it's
also I hate myself because it's like out
of the phone takes me out of the fun but
like I'm running at cuspid like I've
always been like I'm not going to that
that doesn't look like it be fun I'm not
gonna go into that place I'm not that
guys looking at me I'm gonna walk out I
don't want to be I'm just gettin away
from trouble right so I always like if
some girls a little bit like let's I'm
Hannah let's go back to when I was
younger I still remember going nope
this girl's drunk and I don't know where
and I'm not taking her back all right
I'm just not put myself in that
situation yeah and I think they're
people like that and you're right you
miss out on fun but you also take
yourself out of dangerous situations
yeah
and so I've always been that so I know
people who could do like I've seen them
I'm like good person never would do this
sober never would make this bad decision
sober drinking a little too much right
now somebody doesn't keep an eye on that
person they can make a bad decision Wow
and so I don't know it with her I'm not
talking about that bright I never saw
her you don't know if that was she was I
don't know but I'm just saying you know
like I
you were saying people could be on the
cusp of like going down that way but I
just like I know for me that's not you
well I just know I could never think
something that was happening in that was
right and keep going down that going
because I would think oh my god this
seems a little dangerous I you can
better me get arrested for this if
somebody found out oh my god there's a
blast this is bad this is so you
couldn't keep going down that road
unless what unless you had some of that
in you unless you had some of that dark
I don't even know if you had somebody
anyway unless you were easily like you
said coerced or like you know you were
because like what happened with the
Manson the Manson family they said they
pleaded like what that he did what he
yeah like manipulated the people I guess
yeah like they were like oh my god we
just did knock home syndromes have a
thing where he yea they believed they
were easily manipulated like whatever
but they you know and they said that was
the excuse I know that that could never
happen to you
to me right because I but I know old was
she she was young though she was that's
what I'm saying she well she was young
and this man was older apparently that
ran the thing so now I could see that
say a man comes along he has a bunch of
money you know he has access to like a
lot of you know fun crazy stuff maybe
maybe he seems worldly he seems like a
leader of a group you believe in like
I've been to these I did orgasmic
meditation where you I'm driving around
town and you know touch and all you know
see older women's crotches as part of a
club you know like and that's a real
thing and they're really nice yeah what
that's organized and I met other there's
other celebrities in it right like and
not I mean others love is there's
celebrities in it but it's like there
are a lot of different groups out here
there's a lot of people looking for
connection especially in Los Angeles
it's a very disconnected city so if this
girl was 18 he lost 22 easily I could
see her she gets involved with the group
she's she was an attractive girl right
at least sure she was an 8 I don't know
but numbers on anyway it's great myself
at us right she was at least an 8 I
think she was a pretty girl she was
smart she was and this is why it's so
shocking me yes she was younger she
could have easily been mind [ __ ] and
and and given like who knows they could
have said oh and promised her these
things and she was empowered by things
and they somehow she fell down this
there may be all of it too
is just it for me it's shocking just
because it's like to know someone it's
like you know again I said know someone
but I really didn't know her and it just
makes me sad ultimately because yeah it
just makes me sad to know someone who
really was a sweetheart and could be
capable of something like this you know
and we I don't know the whole story but
right it's just it's just it's very
bizarre it's it's it's completely shut
when I saw it I just I looked at Tom
co-star and I looked at you know I
talked to couple I was like I just I
don't know what to say well looks like
the older man whoever ran it looks like
he took advantage of that's exactly her
I feel take advantage of the young man
very probably blackmailed her he
probably manipulated all these with all
these girls were manipulated in
blackmailed and these women and is it's
sad and and it happened and how you hear
about all you hear about you know dark
arts bruh it happens more than you that
it is yeah the the arts yeah dark arts
dark darks you don't think it's the dark
arts dude a man doing that
oh yeah it's dark yeah it is man I agree
who's that on that I don't think it's I
don't know let's hear there's another
fan line yeah we just think one more fan
line question here man and this is a
from our live Ray's fan line you can
submit these online through our youtube
link or through a link on iTunes and you
can submit a question that will come
directly to us via video thank you so
much let's play that Nick hey I got a
question for Rosie and being from
Indiana you know [ __ ] that no ask him a
question about Harlan Williams make him
tell a good story yeah okay so let's
let's see what that wrote listen tell us
a good Harlan story
Harlan's one of the nicest men of the
grace he's one of my best friends the
world we didn't move because sorority
boys years ago they good or not sorta
boys yeah it actually has become a cult
movie people love that movie I really do
genuinely I go to these like conventions
to sign autographs and people come up
and love so he quote sorority boys in
Cicero know
it's a movie socorro Toccara Toccara i
saw the first one is he good cicero
successor oh it's Harlan in that all
right buddy yeah out of the Mafia here
pal hey Theo Harlan Harlan dragged me
he's and I have got some crazy trips he
dragged me to Burning Man and you know I
don't do drugs or anything but I said
[ __ ] it I'm in Burnie man I'm gonna do
Molly mm-hmm and I didn't Molly and it
was a lot of fun and I remember just he
I mean he was wearing a diaper no but I
just remember him like us laughing
constantly yeah we got this RV and he's
to get pissed cuz I was taking a [ __ ]
with the door opens well yeah buddy what
are you doing man I'm [ __ ] sharing an
RV with you and your [ __ ] [ __ ] with
the door open yeah and that's dirty I
remember we came at like 2:00 and I
don't wanna miss anything that's why I
have it open now obviously City Indiana
thing yeah and I just remember coming
home like 4:00 in the morning to the RV
and he's like I'm gonna have a
Thanksgiving dinner but I go alright and
he opens a little fridge in the freezer
it's like this little square small
Thanksgiving meal and one frozen meal
Wow two and a half minutes to make it
and he starts eating it for the money
just stuff in his face it's a curse
delicious bud and I look in the back and
I go you know this has 6,000 calories or
laughs because thanks for ruining
Thanksgiving yeah put it aside but
Harlan's like one of those guys who just
has a heart of gold
yeah always makes me laugh every day I
have text from him this morning just for
does he do that to you mmm oh you don't
know yeah we're not that close you do
communicate well I think he's I think
we've both kind of tried to become a
little bit closer but I think you know
we probably have to do a little bit more
follow through well have a barbecue and
I'll invite you he always he always
comes to those things but he's he's a
treat man he's yeah what do his
Christmas party it was great yeah that's
why I saw yeah it was someone you want
to date no you're so low yeah we're so
low but he and I were both like yeah I
was so low but it was yeah it was fun it
was great time a lot of cute guys
running around Christopher Titus which
was cool because I've always been a big
fan
right yeah yeah Harlan's good he's good
people man he's he's got some crazy
stories uh he took me down the Amazon
River
no because buddy were going to Peru and
I'm like no I don't think so guys like
not buddy we're going on the Amazon
we're gonna see links and we're gonna
see those things that spiders the yeah
oh yeah but it's gonna be and it was was
the most amazing time ever and we swam
like I swam naked he would he had shorts
on but with piranhas yeah in the Amazon
and they just he just he's just fun to
be around see an older brother yeah he's
like it's not one of the top 60 or 70
people I think I've ever met top 67 a
roll people not favor just people yeah
one of the top say I mean it's pretty
good top 60 or 70 yeah I'd say he's
probably top 20 for me for me cuz we're
you know we're closer yeah but still
gonna be no minutes that's a lot yeah
but nine people are family members
something you're not know 11 people
after that if you're do in top 20 that's
pretty good you know how to work like a
real top you know how to work a top
numerical system what do you have to say
Nick is Harland always on over there
ever like a lot of people ask me that
eat conversations with them yeah you
know it's funny cuz when you meet him
like he's always on he's like hey buddy
yeah why don't you your wife yeah how's
your wife doing bought and he's doing
all you know and it's funny because they
don't see the side of him like when his
mom passed away how raw and emotionally
was and how many times we just would sit
there and talk for hours and emotional
and like conversations about just life
and growing up and his dad and you know
girlfriends that I've had or what you
know his XY we would just talk about
real [ __ ] and he's just there for me
when I was going through a breakup he'd
check in all the times like hey bud
leave these message just checking up on
you hope you're okay don't kill yourself
the family loves you and like you would
leave these I have I save all his
messages I have a hundred messages
that I want to make into a special yeah
and just use them all with like it's
just like these three four-minute
messages of Harlem
I have them on here and he just knows
how to make you feel good and he's like
if he's your bud and he loves you he's
there forever he's like one of those
guys yeah yeah yeah he does he does - he
does have such a beautiful he does have
such a beautiful soul he's of really
interesting people don't know him out
there you know he's the dumb and
Dumberer guy he's there's something
about oh yeah I know him right little
your grandpappy's uh
slappy sauce there what did he say it's
so funny chewing on grandpa some
[Laughter]
half-baked when he's talking to the
horse he feeds or horse all that stuff
he's like oh there big girl the black
girl walking on the street he's like
yeah he's one of us I'll say this one of
a kind yeah and your top 60 or 70 yeah
that's good
one of a kind that man yeah there's no I
don't met anybody even at all like you
well I think you have like a certain
personality or on stage especially that
there's a unique there's people who just
go up there and deliver and they just
have funny stuff yeah and then there's a
persona oh you have a persona yeah right
you have like a Carlin has that thing
where he goes and sits and there's
nobody like him like you said he's like
yeah but he's so uh I had the same
problem you know I had the same problem
I had ants all over the place and so I
got really upset so one day I went with
a little bucket and I picked up all
these little [ __ ] and I threw him
into the pool all right and as they were
drown I got this little tear in my eye
you know it's like an emotional and I
ran into the house and I grabbed a box
of Cheerios and one by one I threw him
in the pool to rescue the like so I mean
nobody talks with those ran yeah yeah
and I was always like god I can never be
that funny I can never do that people
always like just be you man this I guess
the most important thing right yeah just
go up and be you yeah I think so man
look I mean I don't know I like autumns
I'm certainly curious to see you know
whatever you create and do next you just
seem to keep staying busy and I
everything comes out of that it's like
yeah you know if you just stay busy
things will happen things you know get
created and you know you get to do fun
stuff and it's exciting you know
yeah that's [ __ ] them again isn't it
yeah they are loved fighter and the kid
who's in there I don't know
you should just bust in there after we
load it up yeah then I can be able to
hear us often I wanna do is see waste of
yelling yes that's the oh he goes it's
up here
we're gonna hear you over here pain
1,400 a month
shut the front door fighter and the kid
they're both gonna get their ass in one
more word out of you and I'm gonna come
over there and them roll your ass all
right
it's Ray Liotta you [ __ ] that ain't Will
Sasso that big [ __ ] Flintstone have
you guys ever thought of silk roofing
this is unprofessional
you [ __ ] kratom junkies lay off the
crate on you crates those guys are
always hopped up on all types of like
rare uppers and snow energy and see ya
oh I hope that's a GNC and venison
what's his name was out there for it
before it opened dude Alan that's huh
Kalin both OH
it was shall but nothing weird we don't
know how begin see before Jesus I mean I
can understand the McDonald's for you
know you're waiting for breakfast but
that's weird
who is it
[Laughter]
they're telling us you were at the GNC
before it open one day I've been farting
yeah you gotta farts in here it's not
gorgeous
who's your guest come over after man
dude half this [ __ ] is your old [ __ ] do
you guys think you should do something
about the sound thing you get your [ __ ]
together you own another cubicle bro
Ryan sardonic really Bryce I look like
your stepdad dude get your [ __ ] life
together dude shape no you sorta look
Croatian bro you got a [ __ ] tighten
up dude why you the third world row you
look third-world successful no if you
don't have to say no you look okay but
no you look fine it's the rest to you
though this [ __ ] is on bro
you tell [ __ ] D'Elia if he wants to
strap to come and [ __ ] get this [ __ ]
dude yes the [ __ ] belt you piece of
[ __ ] and it only costs one hundred
eighty two dollars you cheap [ __ ] dude
the [ __ ] is this huh that's a real knife
a knife yeah and and come to get those
wooden shoes some guy made for you one
time
those are made of solid wood dude
the others are warm living in one of
them yeah get your [ __ ] together dude
know that oh the guy is asthma I'm a
premature baby
that dudes a premature baby dude seven
months and look what he's doing
probably I have a good body one more
strong flex I'm he's gonna break his own
back dude
oh my bad guys get a [ __ ] guess huh
get a gastro ho Wow
back off the kratom back off the kratom
u8u hey your shirt bro dude that shirt
came with school supplies get your
[ __ ] life together dude you're a
child
that shirt is for a fat kid yeah Wow
this happen every popco
know it does and brothers guys are
completely out of line now that was
[ __ ]
that was insane that they live right
next door I mean what are the odds of
that yeah oh it's happened before I mean
just I mean this is the first time
they've come over and started [ __ ]
though yeah we'll see if getting man
yeah I hope it's the end yeah um but I
think we can wrap it up though man it's
been a great episode it's been fun as
[ __ ] man
it's been good fun you're gonna be on
mine yeah well we started yeah I'm
excited too man called inside of you
with Michael Rosenbaum on iTunes it is
it's called inside you with Michael
Rosenbaum on iTunes and genie bus has
come running you just had it on yours
Sean yeah yeah come on yours yeah are
you serious yeah you know best you got
to bring me up your friends I love
Jeanie well the crazy basses is that um
yeah I just messaged her the other day
and said I'd love to have you on and
then I'm looking through your guest and
I was like wow what a smart guy you know
Siri just start talking I don't know but
Jeannie Jeannie is she's an awesome
guest and she's like she's so Oh
talk we talked about her life and [ __ ]
it's great did you guys ever date or no
no no never never never ever so he's
pretty lady she's a beautiful lady very
charming I think I mentioned Phil
Jackson's [ __ ] on my podcast was really
yep I asked if it was big what'd she say
she said just look at his hands she told
me she said I wouldn't take it in the
first round but I draft into the third
or fourth that's what she said
really yeah I think that's a compliment
I don't think so there's only two rounds
an NBA Draft so see I don't know about
basketball so that is an insult how's
that happening Indiana I know man I know
right through thanks Rick started that's
unlike you Nik to talk to me like that
who started this gets effrontery what
was the other hill bipolar but uh yeah
borderline yeah that's Jimmy Chitwood
country isn't it and you [ __ ] didn't
even see that's Larry Bird country
that's [ __ ] Michael Jordan's estate
over Milo and Otis
yeah that's Jimmy Dean down on the farm
Oh Bob Evans Bob Evans down on the farm
[ __ ] yeah dude I had all that [ __ ]
yeah klu klux client yeah well yeah it
was Indiana was it yeah a lot of you
blame the south and I say it a lot I
love Indiana but you know I'm saying
take back your product we didn't start
it do you remember Pizza King Jim pizza
king or pizza chef or druthers uh we had
somebody got killed us out of a little
Little Caesars one time that mr. Gatti's
oh yeah mr. yeah he's daddy's I miss
mello Yello dude mello Yello soda maybe
some Pibb
oh yeah dude my buddy got a can of mr.
pair one time open it it was so thick it
wouldn't even come out of the [ __ ]
can bro how crazy is that so drink it
huh
he he try to suck some of it out you
know and that's America dude that's
America um and I'm trying to give
anything else we wanted to cover not
much and you know Jionni who's uh who
does our book him right yeah he's also I
put I saw he's in it
yeah I hadn't know he was an actor he
doesn't sleep good hockey player though
I watched his Instagram videos he's like
he lives like a bunch of little guys
they're all like how old is he 26:40 he
looks like yes before t if he dyed his
hair on the on the
on the sides he dotted gray on the sides
he could easily be 40 yeah one of those
old sort of like a small judgment yeah
yeah a small Dutchman applying small
Dutchman yeah nice car though nice guy
funny like you've even seen him naked
have you really yeah well I'm in the
locker room yeah with Tom Willy no no I
have you know we get changed in the
locker room I don't I didn't try to see
him naked but you're naked around guys
and yeah what round would you draft him
in yeah oh I didn't lie really didn't
look at it it was like you know those
glances aren't even there kind of just
peripheral like moments that you just
like block out you don't care it's just
a dick it's another dick in the locker
room it's true as soon as you get older
now that's something happens you get
older when you're young you'll look and
you'll take in that dick a little bit
but you're because it's a gel it's an
Envy thing it's not that big a thing but
sometimes if you see a ditch like god
man why is this dick so big
yeah gosh why isn't my dick not as big
as that you know when you're younger and
stuff then you get older you just like I
don't even care I have the dick that I
have do we yeah well we had a black kid
in our junior high school named mr.
Larry right or middle school right he'd
been as vinum oh you've been in school
24 years I think and this was back when
they let you stay in school until you
either got it or they don't let you do
that anymore no or they gave you a job
at the school right so I remember he
would [ __ ] comment while people other
piss her and he would piss over he would
stand behind you and literally he was so
big he could just piss right over you
into the [ __ ] urinal and that was
like his big trick and then they gave
him a job as a um custodian mr. Larry
bro and he was a Sir Larry just kept
working there he was a student and then
just kept working at the institution
he's a student until he just they're
like ah [ __ ] it you know I'm saying you
Errol the atomization he's we got to
keep him student in ain't your thing but
you definitely custodial good here and
people like you and you got a job and
you got a huge [ __ ] and get pissed right
over someone's shoulder [ __ ] town bro
all right that's a good name for this
one [ __ ] town
Michael Rosenbaum you can check out his
podcast it's available on iTunes and
stitcher and every place of podcasts are
available and also short film horror
film he just directed I direct this
movie sure called ha fade into use at
Screamfest and had a movie called the
neighbor with Bill Fichtner is out it's
pretty cool and almost a sorority boys
I'm a that man it's me and Harlan just
being idiots and it's a lot of fun and
ridiculous humor and my movie back in
the day a director with Schwartz inand
Harland and Morena Baccarin from
Deadpool she's in it yeah back in the
day that's I think if you like raunchy
comedies you'll [ __ ] love it it's
really good good good fun farts you see
dicks you see everything hmm yeah we'll
put all the links will put the links to
a couple of those at the top so people
can check them out thanks bro I loved it
man yeah had a good time good to be here
Oh she'll look better with you you look
good you actually you've evolved since
you got here really think man I was you
came in at probably an eighth you're
walking out of probably a strong eight
would I walk in like five I walked in as
I ate yes and I walk out
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this peace of mind I can feel it in the
thought it's gonna take
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]